because whenever like i talk to people
about abortion they always um
make it seem like it's only used in like
chill but no not no no it's not chill
that it's only used in cases of
emergencies and like like
all that stuff but and my feeling is
that it's more used as a form of birth
control today rather than and it's
usually because there's some form of
irresponsibility
so rather than like the exceptions so
that is very so i was a sexual health
advisor for the largest trust in the uk
the british pregnancy advisory service i
don't know the number one i don't know
every single person that i know that's
had an abortion
it was like just them being
irresponsible like it was literally just
them being like i don't know a single
person well i i've in my time in my
position i'd only spoken to one girl who
was like
oh yeah i need an abortion but i used to
know the b pass number but off by heart
it's something like oh 300 300 800 or
300 800 oh i mean i do it off by heart
but the first woman i ever spoke to an
assistant in abortion
she was a married woman
she had two kids her oldest son was
disabled
um she was like even my daughter that we
had was like an accident but a happy
accident and she was like she was
sobbing to me on the phone she was like
in her late 30s and she was like
something maybe say that's not really
like natural if we're like sobbing like
like if that's your reaction to it yeah
yeah no no no but then i was like you
don't need to explain yourself to me i
was like it's not my business i was like
it's not my business not my opinion i
was like you like you've clearly had
like a nice night with your husband your
family like you've got a lot of [ __ ]
going on i was like it's not my business
i was like if you want abortion get an
abortion yeah but then i've also spoken
to
some women who were like
really chill like hey i need an abortion
as if it's birth control yeah and
they're like
um honey like that's
just go just go on proper birth control
you know you know my mom was in a
position where she like like most people
would have advised her to get an
abortion because she was 17 and she got
pregnant
but um by my dad actually at the time
and they actually ended up like giving
up that kid for adoption and he like
he ended up being like a really
successful like sales software engineer
you just got married that's why i
actually have a really hard time
with it because i feel like if anyone
was going to get it it could have been
my mom like she was broke she was 17. so
this is very interesting um
i studied under professor roger ingram
if he's ever watching which he might not
be so i studied um psychology of sexual
health and we did um my personal project
was outcomes of teenage conception yeah
and it's prove all of the research and
you have to obviously look in the bias
all the research shows that it's more
harmful for the woman the better of that
child to have a child and give it up
than it is to have an abortion what do
you what what does that mean it's more
like so the woman for the rest of her
life will be like did i make the right
choice is my child okay rather than
being like i'm gonna have an abortion
and this is why
and so i think i think a lot of times
like again we're making it about us when
it's really it's not about you because
there's a kid in the picture yeah so you
can't you can't you can't you can't then
but then it's like why is that kid more
important than you
why i mean i think in my mom's case like
he grew up to like have a really great
life yeah yeah like and so it kind of
like rubs me the wrong way we don't use
that i think i think that's like why it
rubs me wrong way a little bit when
people are like make it not a life
because like my brother grew up and like
yeah did all these like amazing yeah and
there's always going to be but this is
why so uh roger and groom he's a
professor he's a professor he's like the
best in his field
um he so he literally told everyone he
was like we don't use the term pro-life
right to be pro-life you would have to
be a vegetarian a vegan you won't step
on an ant but you would care about that
woman yeah telling you i want an
abortion because i mean you're you're
either pro-choice or you're
anti-abortion you're not pro-life
because
i need you to clarify that so because
i step on ants yeah because
that doesn't really make sense so that's
well then you're not pro-life because
that's our life that's that's not a
human life
so then you're pro-human life but then
if you're pro-human but like i think
it's like easily implied like like
everyone everyone
let me just ask you do you think there's
a difference between a human life and an
aunt yeah i do but then because it's
still a life it's right but i know but
like you're just kind of trying to get
like a gotcha question like oh it's a
little clearly everything
you
i want an abortion yeah
why is her life
less important
because i don't think just because you
have a kid your life is over
i also think i also think the argument
is that she's in that situation
because of the decisions that she's made
whereas
the consequence is happening to the
child
which is the only innocent party
arguably does that make sense but again
it's like if it's a ball of cells but
also okay what if she's on contraception
and she's taking this like it has a
unique dna sequence yeah like very like
you can see but then why is it
if she doesn't value it why is it
valuable to everyone else and then we go
on to adoption okay if these kids are
valuable why are we overrun in every
western community of like
children get that's it they get your so
do you think the kids aren't valuable if
they're poor i think they're valuable
but they're clearly not being adopted by
people who are pro-life
they're they are there my parents are
pro-life they adopted three kids and you
gave up one but that's but that's just
your personal experience right there's a
lot of people that want to adopt like
even now like yeah it's it's like
could you let me finish um sorry but the
problem is that like the legal systems
are aren't don't make it easy yeah no so
a lot like there's
families that have been waiting for
years to adopt but like they want a baby
they don't want a kid that's been
waiting for years oh for sure that's i
mean i've seen like i've actually seen
the negative like consequences of
getting a kid that's too old it's really
hard to d like if you if you get them
past a certain age a lot of them come
with a lot of issues yeah like this is
it yeah professor washington all of the
right
i think ideally like it would be better
if the kids were adopted earlier rather
than like growing up in foster care
that's not good for any kids yeah but
then they don't get a choice in that
they don't get a say when they're born
that's just a decision made for them by
being forced to be born and there's a
lot of people who
will joke and be like i didn't ask to be
born so i was suicidal for three years
and i was like i didn't ask you born and
my mom will say to me my mom is quite
unwell at the moment my mom will say to
me i wish i bought she was like i wish i
bought you yeah that's really sad
yeah but i know she doesn't mean it i
know she loves me but she's like i have
so much guilt and she was a mum who
carried us to term who looked after us
and she's like i still feel like i can't
provide for you and i'm like no i get it
i understand that you would
not have a lot of guilt you wouldn't
have a lot of like responsibilities like
x y said
um but i'm again it's like it's all true
of a difference i understand that for a
lot of people they're successful stories
for a lot of people
um but for myself individually yeah it's
just very i'm very pro-choice yeah it's
it's not black ops it's just like almost
like we focus on like the negative
stories rather than the positive like
even when me and you talking about this
now like your focus immediately is well
there's all these kids in foster care
that can't get adopted rather than like
the story i just told you of the three
like right you you know it's just weird
how like that that's your immediate
focus rather like there's both you know
what i mean i i i have a question just
played devil's advocate um do you do you
think there is any circumstance where it
is better for a human being not to be
born
than to have a life no matter how much
suffering there is in it
oh that's really hot like let's talk
about ukraine right now like oh i'll
give it i'll give an even better i'll
give you i'll give you a better example
let's talk about slavery
would you say it was better for
a child slave to not be born
than to be born and go through slavery
but then potentially have the chance for
freedom depending oh
that's really hard that's uh it's very
subjective it's very like
because there are some people who go
through [ __ ]
and they're like um so statistically and
anthropology like anthropology
the highest quality of life is seen in
less economically developed countries so
people in like uh nigeria and ethiopia
are actually happier than those of us in
western societies and they've got much
less
and it's because you know the little
things mean more to them so it's like
we look at them as
quote-unquote charity they have more
meaning in their lives we look at them
it's like quote-unquote charity cases
and a lot of westernized people are like
oh africa is poor africa is xbox and
it's like but actually they're very
happy they're very happy with a lot less
than what we are and it's very
subjective it's very like
i do not have the
um i do not have the power to determine
what makes a good life to anyone but
myself but i'm just i'm just asking the
question i'm gonna ask you as well like
do you is there any
is there any circumstance where you
believe that a life being unborn is
better than the life not being born so
a big thing i
love um
yes or no
um i i don't i say i don't have a black
or white yes or no but a big thing a big
fact is so in i believe it's sweden 100
of embryos screened for down syndrome
are aborted 100 percent
because they believe an individual with
down syndrome
won't have a good quality of life
and i fully disagree i work a lot with
people with developmental disabilities
and so people are like oh so if you go
and um i interviewed cambridge and they
said this is the evidence that if you
have if you're pregnant and you live in
a uh built up area and
carbon emissions it means you're more
likely to have a child with autism and
they said okay discuss this with me and
i went i'm not gonna discuss it and they
were like okay why and i said okay so
you're telling me if i live here you
want me to argue about whether or not my
child is more or less likely to have
autism and i just went it doesn't matter
to me and then why and i was like
because if my child has autism i don't
care i was like i will love my child
regardless of how it's born yeah yeah
i just don't understand how you can't
answer that question because nothing's
black or white yes or no it kind of is
like you can either think of an example
or you can't
i can think of an example for pro and
example for con as in like can you is
there any example where you can think of
that a life has so much suffering it was
better that life was never born in the
first place
yeah i could think that but then i could
think the opposite so you can have
something so then so i would then say so
the answer to your question then the
answer to the question originally is
yes as in you do believe that a life it
is better you do believe there's a
situation where it is better for a life
not to be born if its life was to entail
so much suffering
but then that is dependent upon my own
bias and my own
yeah yeah uh
like that's it you say slavery obviously
you'd be like i wouldn't want anyone to
go through slavery but then there are
people who go through slavery who could
be like well actually
this is my reality however xyz is good
about my life so in
spite of slavery
i've got a good quality of life like
it's so who am i to tell you that your
life isn't good like oh no we're just
not just asking for like okay yes or no
like it's all it is
all it is is that can can you think of a
situation
where in your opinion it was better
for that person not to be born than to
go through what they went through in
life
i can't well then i would say that
if you can't then i would say the answer
that is no then you believe that no
matter what suffering that life may go
through you believe that it that human
being being born will always be better
than not being born
but no i don't because that's it
no i don't because that's it it's not
black or white it's not yes or no
everything is the middle part of
everything and like not everything but
technically everything is the gray area
because
i can say for my opinion so that's it my
mom didn't want me to be born she's she
had a mental breakdown two years ago and
was like i wish i never had any any of
you and i'm there like my life is really
good and in her mind she's like your
life is [ __ ] right your projection is
[ __ ] and i'm like no helen like my life
is really good
and so who am i to tell who am i to
decide ah so this is i think it's women
i think i think it's women a lot of
times when you have to admit something
that kind of goes against your belief
system we try to avoid the question and
i think if you if you said that like in
essence like you'd be admitting to
something against your beliefs no i
think that's just that's because it's
the idea
and we don't have a song but something's
like it's a little grounded but it's a
black or white question
but nothing is backwards so i did yeah
dialectical behavioral therapy and
that's what you do with dbt and it's all
to do with no we don't have to be black
or white yeah everything is in the gray
i don't know i don't know what dbt is so
like his but his question is like really
it's really black or white if you can
either think of it example your way of
thinking yeah just to say you have to be
yes or no black or white am i waiting
for this for this question for this
question like it's either well i was
gonna say when when kit said like oh no
and i went well yeah no but then you
expanded upon it and went well but i
don't agree with that part so i agree
with some of the no yeah and i agree
with some of the yes yeah so it's a bit
like
it's it's not
i hear what you're saying i asked you
pearl do you think um there's any
situation you can think of whether it
was better for life not to be born than
to experience that
i mean like
i probably would have aborted hitler
it's probably the only one
i'm like pretty pro-life but like i
probably would have aborted now
like knowing what i know now
um but i mean without like
you can't possibly know so i would say
no
like i can't think of
an example other than hitler yeah
maybe maybe or you know maybe like a
couple brutal murders like i watched
true crime
like what's the difference between
murder and just execution really it's
just perspective i think
but then can we appreciate that that's
not a hard no because you've got an
exception that's a great area that's the
venn diagram i was just i was just
trying to be funny but here i was just i
was just trying to be funny yeah but
there's some truth in it because if
you're saying do you know what because
because in the case of abortion like you
don't know you're never gonna know no
you don't so so what i'm saying is like
i actually
i actually wouldn't abort like hitler
well i'd only abort him knowing what i
know now but that's not a real situation
right so like like and honestly like i
don't think we have the right to play
god
because that's what you're doing you're
playing god then do you believe that
that all depends on if you believe in
god not really i do yeah yeah that's
true
that's true
i'm gonna read some super chats